and I have to plug my self and I
have to sit here and look and talk to a
guy was pushing 40 with that outfit on
it's true
you'd look terrible you look like you're
in a boyband we know that from the 90s I
agree with you it's got worse but bro I
have more money more problems okay man
you know you're making me angry stop
talking about more money no you do know
if you do don't act like you don't know
all I'm saying is you better watch him
tongue around rap because he
runs netflix bro he's on his third
season yeah what you're trying to do you
want your special on Netflix I'll go to
do rapped I got my special we'd say with
the your comedy special yeah he goes
through rap with that same bit you've
been doing for the 70s yeah bag my legs
are like circus animals you bad that's
not my bit I don't say circus animals I
don't have the word so do my thing I
have a short femur bone that's been
there's a joke I'm sad about your thighs
like oh they're like circus and what do
you say I don't remember what I said
about them because I'm so improve on
propositional and I have so many
different I want to say this I want to
say this and I've thought this before
and and I come and I break balls hard
yeah hard yeah I totally don't
understand why you don't have a Netflix
special you got back late from where I'm
a cow travelling comic okay so you got
back late from where the people in
Austin wanted me so I had to give them I
had to give them from from Wednesday to
Saturday
I gave why couldn't you make it back I
couldn't get it early flights I because
they tear my clothes they I can't go to
the airport like what everybody's
private hahaha you have to like going to
disguise a Groucho moisturizer he's
taller in person is he an athlete as
well yeah I get a lot of that stuff so
they want to touch they want to do they
want to get involved what the secret is
at 50 years old are you kid look at my
face at 50 at 50
why what I'm sorry I'm fifth how old are
you rap 46 yeah and I look good good
sixteen years you telling
yourself yeah look at my look at why
what why excuse me yeah listen you know
I get every time I said listen you told
me you looked I got you a t-shirt I got
cuz cuz we're right now it's a soft ass
stick man t-shirt and I got you a double
XL cuz you're a big guy right well I got
my new double XL my back double XL my
back my back is pretty wide from sports
which sportsman what's the stick man
stand for what be shop come on dog
dick man a cocksman okay
someone who see no armies laying the
pipe yeah I said dick man why I don't
know but I should have got you a double
XL because you're a big guy right
because well here is it Bernard but
you're a big guy my back so so I'm
pleased double XL the right size because
you're Lahani my body comes from sports
so my chest I don't worry about why
because when I'm doing sports when I'm
street fighting when I'm power
what I'm doing things like that I'm not
using my chest my everything comes from
my back from my hips so if you look at
my legs if you look at my hips you look
at my back I'm squeezing into a large
risky for me it's gonna be tight risky
especially if I'm throwing some so at
the end of the day my back is an XL but
my front is more of a medium so there's
a real loss so you have to customize so
basically you have to get your t-shirts
Taylor that's the every shirt and you
just asked me Brendan Schaub what a
stick man I don't know you got
that you guys are older
I don't stick man in my jumper are dicks
is his stick he's got long and skinny
right dick is weird you and I have a bit
we've got the actual penis it's about
it's a philosophical thing like a
stickman is this a New York Derek Jeter
stick man Leonardo DiCaprio ladies man
man man but stick I pull out my stick
I think of something long and you know
like your New York you got a stick you
got a sticker B it hasn't hit you know
we're called the bazooka man yeah now
we're talking called a hug OSIS so we
got your hugs your closest what does
that mean you just said you have a long
finger you said you got you poked girls
I punch him you understand I'm saying
brother and it's alright you're laying
jabs were throwing bodies yeah but you
didn't know what a stick man was ow okay
you poker oh so you're not a you
poker I'm a poker yeah Lady Gaga like a
poker face
now I fall yeah you understand yes
with your long pencil like I'm number
two like what it like a little stretch I
get to clean with the culture code
what's it called code here the culture
code here is just would follow my lead
because you're a beta
follow the alpha
follow the oh really a meal with rabbit
yeah I paid I did the joke we
first I ate I pay you saw me downstairs
get my sandwich and you showed up right
after I paid today we gotta say what you
know yeah but you could pay the $13
O'Brien has alligator ups listen know he
had a daughter cuts his hair instead of
paying for here got cuts it here
himself do that be honest with you
Brennan is Brennan doesn't pay and I
paid for your meal no nine dollars here
we go here we go we're in Vegas nothing
like we could add sushi fan hit me up
nothing no you were House working
non-stop when you had on those
shoes you're done a Gucci like but
like they were like Prince boots yeah
yeah but you were we're suck the boys up
no why don't you go get me a
almond milk lot yeah yeah good for
nothing meal - you guys are making me up
bein a male right now and I'm into
sports I know Stefan Carl's Steph Curry
went off gold state obviously the it's
almost unfair how do your eyebrows do it
now I'm doing three TV shows now what
are the TV show you're doing the
Goldberg yeah I won't spin off on ABC
will get you apart but mostly what
happens and then I got give you shot
that yet now I have a shot that yep
about to about two and TV probably won't
be the same doesn't matter and then
what's the third show did you make that
up into Kingdom Kingdom I'm on Kingdom
that's the one Yap I like that show
that's the guy oh that actor I like girl
what Frank Grillo
that's the guy you you him right
he you bet him he's talking about
Frank Carillo
I didn't know Frank Grillo its grill
don't say gorilla it's Colonel Carrillo
yeah say it right I was learned that he
should be you should be
you let him I don't do that man he's my
good buddy and don't say that but he's
like I was a man crazy I'm not
if it said my guy Frank you know he's
good-looking he's an ass-kicker he's
gonna be a big star but like he's a
good-looking he's got a great jawline
like he'll kick anybody's I'm
like okay you know Frank girl I'm like
you just told me about him yesterday
Frank has he been on
gorilla yeah not even considered guest
of the year all right take it easy
no I'm just saying like okay but don't
be competitive here he's not Michael
Rapaport on the mic we'll put it down
but Frank yo fire your publicist fire
your manager you higher walking talking
no boys man man me
it's a cafeteria
no you know what though I like that you
said boy because I got such a youthful
Peter Pan vibrator fit you do it he's be
my prince easier is no Peter Pan yes
vibrancy is what comes to your mind when
you look at me
yes vibrancy yes that's that's what
comes to my mind yeah so anyway um I'm
pretty down with most of the current Oh
Kevin Hart Oh Bieber star in the
you know anybody who loves
celebrities more than Brian can I sure
don't you got a point there
I mean he will suck off a celebrity at
the drop like he'll just like run up
like he'll do like a James Brown slide a
dick his knee Oh dick dive behind the
the certified dick diver Jesus pure
celebrity organ dick he loves it he
loves him but you
this is the crossover kid man this
crossover kid this is the problem though
you guys get twisted you think I'm like
Ice Cube we're gonna have to have some
fun
you're not nobody up come they
late every single time it's so
rude so rude it's disrespect but I'm
training my training schedule you're not
training jack if you relate all time on
set would you have a job he'll know I
know he's not late for the Goldbergs or
his other showing not only that what
they don't stop everybody oh that with
your imagine him on a set like around
all their like legitimate people no I
get serious but I know you you by acting
you give me anything right now I'll do
something without your craft I can
do crazy drama right now I can put it on
like that what whatever you want dude I
do like what like I don't know anything
dude anything be like a mom be like okay
baby I'll be a white rapper you're on
white famous you're the white rapper
there's no white rappers on white this
new I know the role they should have had
this
so when he got canceled yo yo I need
some wrap up in this right
here here yes that's pretty good selling
they Tina's I need some wrap
yeah I need some wrap up in this
right here is that only 20
Sarat I need to wrap up in his mouth all
right I'm about nobody my buddy Jimmy
Burke in New York used to do that to me
I would do a show no one knows Jimmy
Burke is I know it's your friend but
it's like the people at home like
they're like no one cares about you they
do they know respected Jimmy no no no
they don't
he's the Prince of New York and they all
know and they're all going yeah Jimmy
tell us mother story no yeah you know I
don't know who the Jimmy burns I
know another guy named Jimmy Burke and
it's not even you he would have a group
of losers goes my friend yeah but he'd
have a group of young actresses and the
theme of the show today is Brian is
Brendan outgrowing you Wow are you see
basically like are you like a duffle bag
you know when you go to the airport lot
you know when you travel like Mexican I
don't like this deal at all but you know
when you travel like Mexico and you're
like you could just have one carry-on
yeah but if you if you if you can't get
go on Karen you're gonna have to check
everything your that check the bag don't
you dare and we're talking about
in Mexico we're not talking about a
great Airport in Mexico we're not like
with then we got to go get you off the
bag like all right Brian
don't you ever I am not extra baggage to
say these deadweight they don't see it
first you were the guy yeah and you were
like doing this sad sack a favor
yeah okay and how many episodes are we
in here on the showings okay 500
whatever and and now it's like careful
your that bag into you know right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]